Johnny's with us in Phoenix hey Johnny
how are you it how you did better than I
deserve what's up awesome um so a my
wife and I we started your plan back in
January about we paid off about fourteen
thousand dollars in debt yeah and we
didn't have one thing that's been kind
of eating at us the whole time our
situation that my parents have a kind of
an investment house that they bought and
we lived there we basically just pay all
utilities they don't charge us for rent
or anything like that and they also have
a car that we use but we're just kind of
we use their cars and we're just kind of
we feel bad bad because we know we want
to be independent and all that stuff
while we're paying off our debt
how much debt I thought how much do you
have left we have about forty four
thousand hopefully ask your student loan
and what's your household in at all um
right now probably about sixty thousand
why about you don't know what your
household income is I just got a
promotion at work so and then so my wife
also just quit her job
so we're what a shot what did she quit
her job if you're trying to get an event
that's just our situation we we have a
kid at home and we'd rather have him be
at home and my income is should be going
up substantially there's this next
couple months
no kanji only work can we worked at
twice a month
anyway we only made a couple hundred
bucks a month so it wasn't that big of a
difference oh I see okay so what do you
think your income will be in the coming
12 months um it's probably going to be
around sixty five seventy thousand okay
and what did
did it used to be before you got this
new pad so last year I did about 50,000
well yeah I got about a $20,000 raise
okay and so that means that easily you
ought to be debt-free within 18 months
yeah the plan is could be debt-free by
the end of next year end of 17 that's
pretty aggressive good okay well I would
I Drive a borrowed car and live in a
borrowed house for basically thirteen or
fourteen more months to finish out my
debt-free plan as long as it's not
putting a strain on your parents yes I
would
you're right that is it's a wonderful
nice gift that they're giving you and
it's not the way you want to live from a
dignity standpoint forever
but for a short period of time for a
one-year plus plus or minus period of
time to finish off all of this debt yeah
I'd do that for a short period of time
and then the first thing I'm going to do
after that is you know get my emergency
fund in place and buy a car then the
next thing I'm going to do start to look
up think about how I'm going to have
housing that my parents aren't providing
for free but and you know get get it get
it up to where you're self-supporting
but what I for a short period of time
accept this wonderful generous gift if
it's not putting a strain on them in
order to accomplish this goal that's
very much in front of you and that
you're very intense and focused on yes I
would and it sounds like you are very
your math tells me you're pretty intense
yeah I plan on doing as much overtime as
I can at work I can do a lot and just
work my butt off yeah and she's at home
so she's a full-time home economist
meaning the kids are in consignment sale
clothes she's the coupon queen and she's
cooking from scratch baby
I mean we're milking every dollar out of
this budget right oh yeah yeah and both
of you are on this bond board to do that
if that's the case then again yes for a
short period of time I would do that
um you know when we went broke all those
years ago
I had a friend of mine loaned me a car
for three months it was a horrible car
but it was a car and
had it for three months and it was a
huge blessing made me never want to be
that broke again driving that old piece
of crap but it was still a wonderful
blessing I mean it was a 1978 Cadillac
with four hundred seventy eight thousand
actual miles on it the vinyl roof was
torn loose so when you drove it it
filled up with air I had a parachute on
top of the car it was awful
predominant color on the thing was bondo
it was awful
but it ran and it got me around for
three whole months I drove that car for
ten years one three month period that's
how it felt you know what I'm saying
yeah yes I accepted help I was broke I
was getting my butt out of there where I
was never going back and of course I
have never gone back but man what a
wonderful thing that guy let me use that
old car and you know it was just up in
the weeds at his house and there was a
reason it might be up in the weeds but
when you're up in the weeds you go get a
car that's up in the weeds right it's
what you do so but it's only we're going
to drive like no one else so later we
can drive like no one else we're going
to live like no one else so later we can
live and give like no one else and
that's what you're doing sir you're on
track you're going to do well and I'm
proud of you a very very very good job
hold on I'm gonna have Kelly pick up if
you guys are not in Financial Peace
University class I want you to be in
there as my guest the two of you need to
be going through that class and have the
encouragement to really lean in and
finish this program that you're on
you're doing good work I'm proud of you
very good hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show